[Music]  not fair bling lark booty cow  what about your husband the hell are you  I'm Vinny are you not Jaime my naughty  Craigslist honey I'm calling the bodies  the ten rules to a healthy open  relationship how is your sex life it's  fine my point precisely you got to spice  it up by banging other girls I wanna  worship your ass start by asking  yourself are you out of your mind I  couldn't handle it  I mean where it starts what to put where  who to do first  thank will you have a threesome with me  will three never ever ever ever say I  love you don't get it girl you came down  here to rob the cradle mrs. Robinson  I love him how are you gonna stroll in  uninvited to the party of this summer  [Applause]  [Music]  okay died of purchase  [Applause]  [Applause]  great gonna have some guys Paul's in my  face